In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion from A23rd, on which we commemorate our righteous father,
Michael the Confessor, Bishop of Sinada.
On the 23rd of the month we celebrate the memory of our venerable father, Michael the Confessor,
Metropolitan of Sinada.
Born in Sinada, in Frigia, St. Michael early left his homeland for Constantinople, where
he linked himself in spiritual friendship with Saint Thelfiluctus.
The two young men showed such great unity of thought and feeling that they were seen
as one new man.
When St. Tarasius, after having received the monastic habit was raised to patriarchal dignity,
the two friends became monks in their turn in the monastery he had founded on the Bosphorus.
Rivaling each other in ascetic striving, they made rapid progress in virtue, enhanced by
the glorious adornment of humility and the constant gaiety of their souls.
Tharasius informed of their great feats, appointed them Scevo-Filaxes of the Great Church, and
shortly afterwards succeeded in making them against their will, except episcopal consecration.
Thelfiluctus as Metropolitan of Nicomedia and Michael to be pastor of his homeland, Sinada.
Rightly proclaiming the word of truth both by his teaching and his life, patient and merciful,
having overcome anger, this good shepherd had churches and monasteries built and founded
hospices and charitable institutions to help the sick, the destitute and the strangers.
Bishop Michael was present at the Second Council of Nicaea in 787, where he upheld the Orthodox
doctrine of the veneration of the Holy icons, then on returning to his diocese quietly resumed
his pastoral work.
In 806, the year in which the Holy Patriarch Nicaferos succeeded the departed St. Tharasius,
St. Michael was sent by Emperor Nicaferos to lead an embassy to Caliph Harun Al-Rashid,
in the course of which he gave proof of all his qualities as a man of peace and conciliation.
In the autumn of 811, he was sent to Rome as Patriarch Nicaferos' legate to present his
synodical letters to the Pope and to assure him of his support concerning the veneration
of the Holy icons.
The following year he was received by Charlemagne at Ex-Lashapella and secured a peace treaty
with him.
After he had reigned for two years, the new emperor, Leo V, the Armenian, unveiled his
dark designs and restarted the persecution against the Holy icons, St. Michael immediately
allied himself with the defenders of the true faith, who had gathered with Patriarch Nicaferos,
Othemias of Sardis, Joseph of Thessalonica, Emilianos of Zizekus, the Ophiloptus of Nicomedia,
and many others, clergy, monks, and layfolk who held themselves ready to shed their blood
for the faith.
They presented themselves before the sovereign and tried to bring him to reason, both with
arguments taken from the Holy Fathers and by reminding him of the support they had from
the Church of Rome, but it was in vain, and, blinded by his fury, the tyrant had them arrested
and sent into exile far from one another and with a ban on their corresponding.
St. Michael was sent to Odysseus and Fridia, where he remained for more than ten years,
suffering all the ill-treatment he received with thanksgiving and praying for his persecutors.
He would not for anything cease defending the Orthodox faith and being ready to help
the unfortunate, and he maintained unchanged his program of ascetic life and nocturnal prayer.
He worked many miracles there, healing by his prayer and the honey of his words, both men
and domestic animals, and succeeded in taming and converting the rough and uncouth inhabitants
of this remote region.
The emperor, learning that exile was turning for the saint into an increase of glory, ordered
that he be transferred somewhere else.
Wandering hither and thither, the man of God came to a land infested with a multitude of rats
that were ravaging the crops.
He explained to his inhabitants that the plague had been sent by God as a punishment for their
sins, and ordered them to spend three days in fasting and repentance.
In this time had passed, he called them to go, all together into the fields.
While the people cried, Kirie Eleison, the saint knelt and interceded for them, his hands
and eyes turned heavenward.
An earthquake immediately shook the region, and all the rats perished.
Moving to another place called Oranticia, the inhabitants begged him to pray that they be
delivered from the uncountable hordes of grasshoppers, which were ruining their crops
and fruit trees, threatening them with famine.
The saint spent the night in prayer, and early in the morning went at the head of a procession,
in which all the people of the land took part, singing Kirie Eleison.
The grasshoppers gathered together on a thick, dark cloud which rose into the air and disappeared.
The saint continued his wanderings, driven from place to place, shedding God's mercy on
men and on their crops.
Finally, after having spent some time in prison in Constantinople, he was exiled once more
to the shore of the lake of Nicomedia, where other confessors of the faith were waiting until
the good pleasure of Emperor Michael, the Stammerer, allowed them to rejoin their dioceses or
monasteries.
Aged more than 90, exhausted by his trials, Saint Michael continued no less to pray for the
emperor, for the peace of the church, for the salvation of the world, and for the abundance
of the fruits of the earth.
On the Monday of Pentecost in the year 826, while leaving a meal organized by his longtime
friend Saint Theodore, the stoodite, with whom he had never stopped corresponding during
his exile, the holy prelate seized with a sudden malady, had to take to his bed.
On the next day, Theodore found him in the throes of terrible pain, and on the third day,
the Wednesday of Pentecost, Saint Michael, who had lost the power of speech, breathed his
last, in the presence of his friend and companion, in striving, after forty years of episcopate.
His lifeless body, Saint Theodore writes, looked like an angel, and shone with flashes of
divine light, which so many years of prayer and contemplation had imprinted on it.
The relic of his precious head, offered as a gift to the great Lavra of Saint Athanasios
on Athos by Emperor Basil II and his brother Constantine VIII in 978, lies venerated there
to the present day, and continues to work miracles to protect the crops from predatory animals,
both those belonging to the monastery, and those in the regions to which it is sent.
Under the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.